welcome to the show everybody so you
know how I always say many conservatives
always say that the left is beyond
parity at this point well that's not a
mere platitude or a slogan there is a
deep and terrifying truth here and the
truth is that they actually are beyond
parity as in it's becoming impossible to
satirize them because satire requires
that you take the idea your satirizing
and you bring it to an absurd conclusion
so as to highlight the the flaws within
the logic that you're trying to make a
satire of but if the idea that is being
proposed to begin with is has already
been brought to its most absurd
conclusion then what can you do all you
can do to satirize it is to point to it
and say look and that's what satire is
increasingly becoming case in point CNN
I suppose I could just stop right there
but let's let me give you a specific
example here's a headline of a real
article on cnn.com right now this is
real I assure you written by a certified
genius named Brandon tensley headline
coronavirus task force another example
of trump administration's lack of
diversity no it gets it gets better I
show you it's it is um it the
expectations set by that headline are
fulfilled within the text of the article
let me read it to you it says it's a
statement that's as predictable as it is
infuriating
President Donald Trump's administration
lacks diversity on Tuesday Trump tweeted
photos of a briefing he'd received on
the new coronavirus spreading out of
China the president said in his post we
will continue to monitor monitor the
ongoing developments we have the best
experts anywhere in the world and they
are they are on top of this 24/7 who are
these experts they're largely the same
sort of white men and a couple women on
the sidelines who've dominated the Trump
administration from the very beginning
by contrast former President Barack
Obama circle of advisors in the face of
2014 as a bola outbreak in West Africa
was hardly so monochromatic neither was
it so abysmal in terms of gender
diversity of course to contextualize
Obama administration's on the other hand
on the whole was far more diverse than
Trump's and yet as unsurprising as the
diversity issue in the Trump era has
become it's still worth pointing out
from time to time
especially as the country approaches the
2020 presidential election in earnest
that's partly because the recent photos
of the best experts Telegraph the kinds
of people the administration deems
worthy of holding power and even being
in close proximity to it they
communicate a patronage network that
everyone is operating under as Eric
Yellin an associate professor of blah
blah blah okay but the visuals have come
to define the Trump administration and
they say something else too they signal
which which people in a multiracial half
female country Trump values the opinions
of mostly white men who are mirror
images of the President himself now look
the easy thing to do here would be to
show you the the page on CNN's own
website with with photos of their
anchors and their correspondence and and
you know you would see if you look at
this page that jeez I mean that's that's
a lot of whiteness right there Wow look
at this just white white white white
white I need sunglasses looking at this
it's so much whiteness I haven't seen so
many white people since I went to a
clearance sale sale at HomeGoods or you
know in fact I haven't seen this much
whiteness since I watched the Democratic
debates this is just a lot of a lot of
whiteness so we could do that and point
out that CNN is not holding itself to
its own standard but that wouldn't be
fair it's not fair because it's not fair
to hold them to their own standards
totally unfair they get a special
standard you see we all have one
standard and they're special they have a
different one all right that's just the
way it is it's the way it is and it's
the way it should be for some reason I
can't explain why but it is what I
really want to say is all joking aside
because this is a serious issue and we
shouldn't joke about it so completely
sincerely my first reaction yet is to
mock and laugh at this article but I
think you should resist that urge we all
should and we should try to listen to
what this man is saying because he's
actually right you know the whole point
of a task force is of this task force is
to help monitor and contain
this disease and to stop it from
spreading here but let me ask you this
do you really want you have to think
about this do you really want a bunch of
cisgendered white men to protect you
from a deadly virus sure if they're
successful the positive is that you
don't die a horrible death
death leaving your children orphaned and
your spouse destitute that's the
positive but does that even come close
to compensating for the lack of
diversity is it worth the cost is what
I'm trying to ask you you continuing to
live and not get a deadly disease is
that worth the cost of the lack of
diversity that's quite an ethical
dilemma you have to admit personally
here's my thing I'm an agreement with
CNN on this when you're dealing with a
potential pandemic the key is to make
sure that the people combating it the
people that are tasked with containing
it are adequately representative of
every demographic so if it were me as
someone who is not a bigot I'm gonna
have a task force with of course black
people Latinos women lesbians pansexuals
transgenders probably I'll throw a
couple agent Asians in there bisexual
Asians just to be just to be safe if if
a white person makes it on the team they
damn well better be drag queens at a
minimum what about a gay white man
sorry not progressive enough you're
gonna need to do a lot better than that
now you want to talk about a disabled
gay white man okay maybe now you're
talking okay what if these people though
don't have expertise in containing
deadly viruses what if there are other
people who would have more expertise and
perhaps would be better suited for the
job doesn't matter because that's not
the point
the point always is to promote diversity
in every situation no matter what and
that way my diverse progressive
tolerance taskforce if it fails to
contain the virus because none of them
have any relevant expertise or any
relevant experience in the field of
Epidemiology well then as you're lying
there dying you at least will have the
peace of mind of knowing that there are
no straight white males on the
coronavirus task force and you know
something I think that will bring you a
lot of peace and comfort in your final
moments so thank you to CNN for that
really really wonderful wonderful stuff
now more to talk about but I'm super
excited to tell you about our new
sponsor to Co VA's when I found out that
the koba's was sending me some of their
cowboy boots I felt like the kid in you
know Christmas story waiting for the the
BB gun very excited I told my wife I
want to start doing a whole cowboy
aesthetic now and in fact to be honest
with you my wife if I'm being honest was
skeptical at first about the cowboy boot
thing and I think it's because she had
something in mind sort of like this
something tacky and garish in mind I
don't know but then they came and even
she admitted that these are some damn
fine boots I'm paraphrasing it's not
exactly what she said but but that was
the that was the sentiment and I
absolutely love them I'm wearing them
right now as we speak in fact and I just
can't recommend them enough to koba's
cowboy boots are handmade with high
quality full grain leather x' by
world-class boot makers they're built to
be comfortable right out of the box and
I can attest that they are and they're
for every occasion at home in the office
out on the town with tons of timeless
styles to koba's are designed to be as
fashionable 50 years from now as they
are today and to Kobus cuts out the
middleman it sells directly to you at an
honest price that's truly amazing
considering the the level of quality
these are by far the nicest this is the
nicest Footwear I've ever had but not
the most expensive so I should tell you
everything you need to know in addition
to cowboy boots to Kovas makes leather
duffels men's jeans belts billfold card
cases and more everything you get from
Tekoa va's comes with the same
calculated approach and quality
standards that hold true to everything
they do I love these boots I really do
can't recommend them enough I've got my
eyes on the jeans and belt next
I think because you want to make sure to
pair the cowboy boots with the right
kind of jeans so I'm gonna be doing that
as well do what I did get yourself a
pair of Tacomas cowboy boots today at to
go viscom slash walsh that's tec ova
s.com slash walsh tacomas dot-com slash
walsh all right here's some more
unintentional satire because these are
fun article from Gizmodo billionaire
Jack Ma has donated 14 million dollars
to develop a corona virus vaccine
roughly the equivalent of an average US
family donating 33 dollars of the
article format Novak reads in part tech
billionaire Jack Ma has donated 14.5
million dollars to help develop a
vaccine the corona virus mah is China's
wealthiest person with an estimated 41
billion dollars which means that his
donation is roughly equivalent to the
average American household donating 33
bucks ma founded Alibaba the world's
largest online retailer and is often
compared to Amazon Alibaba and Amazon
both treat their employees like s like
crap their owners both own major media
outlets Bezos who's worth an estimated
one hundred seventeen billion dollars
recently donated six hundred ninety
thousand dollars to help Australia
battle its bush fires that bastard the
equivalent of an average American
donating less than a dollar how generous
coming from a guy who says he doesn't
know how to spend his money Bezos and ma
would get along just swimmingly it's
good when extremely wealthy people give
their money to worthy causes but you
know what's great
taking that obscene wealth through taxes
and spending it to make the world a
healthier place for everyone yet again
yet again we have an article here this
is a leftist expressing their actual
point of view but if you were to take
this article headline everything and put
it on the bat the Babylon be it wouldn't
seem out of place at all you could take
this article verbatim and put it on a
satire site and everybody would have a
nice laugh the only reason I'm
acknowledging this particular tripe is
that this is a common attitude these
days this thing where a billionaire
gives a million dollars or gives
millions of dollars to a cause and then
people go well that's like if I gave 15
cents except it's not okay
14 million dollars to fight a disease is
the equivalent of 14 million dollars to
fight a disease the money isn't suddenly
worth less because it comes from a rich
guy that's not how it works
14 million dollars is 14 million dollars
is 14 million dollars this is like if I
was starving and a guy pulled up with a
truck full of sandwiches with 600
sandwiches and he gave me one sandwich
so I didn't starve and then I say hey
you given me one sandwich is like a guy
with two sandwiches giving me three
crumbs and I throw it back in his face
and starve to death in protest no see
the nutritional value of the sandwich
doesn't fluctuate depending on the
relative sandwich wealth of the person
who hands it to you the sandwich is the
sandwich by the way did the are did the
author of this article he says it's like
a normal person donating 33 but okay
well did did you as the author of the
article did you did you donate 33 bucks
because if he didn't then Jack Ma is
still more generous even by his bizarre
math I can tell you that and I will
admit I don't know about you I have
donated zero point zero dollars to
developing a corona virus vaccine I have
given no money to that effort
I have not contributed to that effort at
all I haven't done anything for it
personally I'm ashamed to admit
so anything that a billionaire does is
going to be infinitely more than I have
done because I've done nothing and I
think that's probably true of the guy
who wrote this article it's probably
true of almost all of us almost
everybody watching right now or
listening I bet you have done almost
nothing with respect to the corona virus
that's the thing about these people who
try to dismiss the charitable endeavors
of billionaires they say if him giving
six hundred million dollars is like me
giving three quarters in a t.j.maxx gift
card making up these arbitrary
valencies but these people doing that
how many of them are actually giving any
money to any charitable causes at all I
mean even 33 dollars or ten dollars or
five
I bet many of them are giving zero none
I'm betting you they sit there arms
crossed rolling their eyes at people who
are helping while doing nothing not just
sitting there but they're doing more
they're doing less than nothing because
they're sitting there criticizing those
who are helping while they don't
contribute at all
they're like somebody sitting down at a
construction site eating a candy bar
watching men lug heavy things around and
saying that's easy for them look how big
they are that's easy to pick up any
stuff while they lift nothing do nothing
contribute nothing of value whatsoever I
I think that's probably what happens but
what is this all in service to it's all
in service to insisting on on as they
say at the end of the article take the
money through taxes they say their
position is we need the government to
take control take the money because we
can't trust these people to be
charitable with their own money and then
when they are charitable with their
money because that interferes with the
narrative now we're gonna say well yeah
they were charitable but it's it's it
doesn't really mean anything because X Y
Z it's extremely pathetic but I will
anxiously await Matt Novak the author of
that article I'll be anxiously waiting
to hear how much you have donated
personally to develop a corona virus
vaccine all right what else do we have
here one other article or subject to
tackle before we get the emails I want
to leave some time for emails because we
were talking about the issue of corporal
punishment spanking during the email
portion of the show and then I was
getting into it on social media which is
always a
good use of time arguing about complex
important issues on social media anyway
a lot of emails about that and and I
want us I want to get back into that
subject but first this reading from an
article in the New York Post by Andrea
Peyser it titled far-left agitprop for
pre-k tots what NYC schools have come to
I'm not going to read much of this but
just to give you the gist in an email
says in an email to parents and
caregivers on January 16th teacher Rosie
Clark lays out lessons based on the
black lives matter week of action for a
pre-kindergarten class at PS 58 located
in the well-regarded district 15 in
Carroll Gardens this from teacher Clark
writes this year who was white by the
way this week this year the week
February 3rd through 7th we're starting
to talk about these ideas now as we
approach Martin Luther King jr. Day
which was January 20th and as we prepare
to go into the February Black History
Month I am lucky enough to work at this
wonderful school where we strive to help
our students understand the complex
world around them and think critically
about how they can participate in
improving it one of the ways I do that
in my classroom is by exploring the 13
principles of the movement for black
lives so this is a white preschool
teacher who is teaching her preschool
students so preschool you're talking
like four years old teaching a bunch of
four-year-olds the 13 principles of
black lives matter because this is what
we want our preschool tree teachers to
be doing right the author of the
articles continues some of the 13 points
are unobjectionable preaching diversity
plus acceptance and empathy to children
who the dad argues naturally love their
neighbors this by the way is coming from
a dad who alerted the author of the
article to this that this was going on
then there's principle six transgender
affirming everybody has the right to
choose their own gender by listening to
their own heart and mind everyone gets
to choose if they're a boy or a girl or
both or neither or something else and no
one gets to choose for them then number
seven queer affirming the principle here
is that everybody has the right to
choose who
they love and the kind of family they
want to do they want by listening to
their own heart and mind and then
there's number 12 black women the
teacher writes there are some people who
think that women are less important than
men we know that all people are
important and have the right to be safe
and talk about their feelings now who
are these people who think that women
are less important than men I don't know
but this is what we're telling
preschoolers okay there's more to this
article you can go to NY post calm and
read it it's worth the read of course
I'm mainly zeroing in on principle
number six transgender 1/3 affirming
everybody has the right to choose their
own gender by listening to their own
heart and mind everyone gets to choose
if they're a boy or a girl or both or
neither or something else and no one
gets to choose for them now I talk a lot
about how left-wing gender theory is
inherently nonsensical and impossible to
explain or defend and I've speculated
that most people who believe or who
pretend to believe this who espouse it
don't really believe it and most of the
people who pretend to believe the ones
that are espousing it don't themselves
actually believe it and I base this on
the fact that ten years ago almost
nobody thought that a dude could really
be a woman magically if he feels like
one almost nobody thought that ten years
ago ten years ago and any time prior
almost nobody was advocating for men to
be allowed in the women's locker room or
to be allowed on the women's track team
and so on and then almost overnight
there's this shift and it it I really
doubt that all of these people who had
lived their lives up to that point
believing that biological sex exists it
seems unlikely to me that they overnight
could have really authentically
sincerely changed their minds so I don't
think that really happened I think that
they're pretending but here's here's the
other part of those because the left
knows that they can't defend their
position they know that most sane adults
don't believe it never will they know
that if they asked almost any adult
whether dude
should be able to play on a girls
basketball team and if that adult was
able to be honest felt safe and felt
that they could they could answer
honestly without without facing some
sort of repercussion almost any adult
would say no they shouldn't be allowed
to and that's why they're focusing on
children left display the long game
they've always played the long game
they've never been overly concerned with
a short-term situation to their credit
they're looking for at this from a
generational perspective that's why they
win that's why they've won the culture
because they're looking generations down
the line and they know that if they can
get to the if they can get to the kids
if they can convince the kids it's not
gonna matter what you think or what I
think it's irrelevant
who cares about us get to the kids
recruit the kids brainwash them and then
you have the culture you have everything
and a good thing for them for the
left-wing brainwashers is that kids
especially preschool age kids can be
convinced of literally anything
so I say convince the kids that's really
easy you know you know what's involved
in convincing a four-year-old of
something tell them whatever you want to
convince them tell them and that's it
they're convinced that's all you have to
do because four-year-olds lacked the
cognitive tools to discern truth from
fiction plausibility from implausibility
reality from fantasy they can't do that
all that a child at that age can do is
rely on the word of the adults in his
life that's the most rational thing for
him to do because he doesn't know
anything about the world and so he's
going to rely on the adults around him
he has to do that because there
not going to understand the whys of
things hi you know I the other day I
caught my three year old trying to put
his finger in a power outlet and of
course I stopped him and I was very
stern with him and I explained to him
that he can't touch it because he'll get
very very hurt but of course he had no
idea what I was talking about
electricity shock death injury what does
any of that mean to a three-year-old it
doesn't doesn't mean anything to him
he just he has my word and that has to
be enough and to him there's no
difference between one incomprehensible
claim that an adult might make and any
other so if you know he'll take my word
for it on the outlet thing if I were to
tell him don't walk on the grass because
a dragon will come out of the ground and
eat you he believed that - he'd believe
it just like he believed the outlet
story to him they're exactly the same he
doesn't see a difference he can't
measure plausibility verse
implausibility so if you get to them the
left knows this convince them then it
doesn't matter then you don't have to
define it you don't have to defend it or
or define your terms I I'm always
talking about can you define the word
woman and how that is a pretty
conclusive counter-argument all of this
gender madness and it is but what the
left is saying is who cares yeah we
can't defend it we don't need to because
we're gonna get your kids and here's the
other part of this many of us I think
still don't understand this about
ourselves the thing is when you get to a
kid and you you tell a kid something
they're gonna believe it but they're
also they're going to continue believing
it in perpetuity unless you tell them
otherwise or unless they're convinced
otherwise by other adults you see the it
a kid something at that age it has such
a lasting long-term impact that kids
will all the way into adulthood could
continue believing something that is
completely absurd and nonsensical just
because they were told it as a kid
unless somebody else comes back around
and candy program but if that
deprogramming never happens they're
gonna live their whole life believing
that and I you know that's the true for
a lot of us too that what we're taught
as a child whether true or not whether
defensible or not whether reasonable or
not whatever you're taught will maintain
a very strong hold over you well into
adulthood and possibly forever it is
very very very hard for an adult to
break away from the indoctrination that
he experienced as a youth because that
stuff gets seared into the brain the
mind forms around it and to extricate it
is extremely difficult point being tell
preschoolers that boys are girls and
they'll believe you because you said it
and they lack the capacity to know the
difference and if you keep telling them
most of them will continue believing it
just as strongly you know at the age of
26 and 36 and 56 as they did when they
were 6 but most people go their whole
lives basically believing everything
they were taught as kids
most people with most things not all but
if you can
this Jenner this this young generation
of kids they can convert them then the
game is over
because indoctrinated at that age even
as adults it's it's going to it's going
to be almost impossible at that point to
convince them otherwise alright I want
to get to emails before we do we've been
talking for the last several weeks about
the pro-life issue and how important it
obviously is and and and what the left
has been doing to shut down and censor
those of us who stand for the for the
pro-life cause and we've gone through it
ourselves with with people coming after
our sponsors and so on and we've been
telling you about live action which is
one of the biggest most important voices
in the pro-life movement and they've in
in terms of attacks from the left they
get it worse than almost anybody and
that's why until January 31st which is
today a portion of any Daily wire
membership but we donate it to live
action with promo code live action and
that's today is your last day to do this
so if you if you go right now you sign
up use the promo code live action to
support awareness and education around
the world in this issue join daily wire
do it right now
make your pro-life voice heard and at
the same time you're also gonna be a
member of The Daily wire so it's it's a
win-win for everybody go do that right
now
well not right now wait till the show's
over and then go do it okay bundles of
mail talking about the spanking issue
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail combat while show
at gmail.com I was going to read a bunch
of the emails I think I'll just read one
that lays out the objection to my
arguments pretty well and I'll respond
to those and and and that will be the
conclusion of this topic for now okay
this is from Joel it says hi Matt I love
your show but totally disagree with your
spanking take I think to say that those
of us who spank our kids are bad parents
is very wrong and judgmental you say
that spanking is do as I say not as I do
but don't you do many things your kids
can't do you put them in timeout but you
don't you wouldn't let them do that
you take their toys but you don't let
them take from other people also you say
that spanking is hitting you call that
the dictionary definition it's not this
is the dictionary definition of spanking
to strike a person usually a child with
the open hand etc especially on the
buttocks as in punishment
what about shouting it's easy to judge
parents who spank but I say shouting is
worse
/ abusive you can make all the arguments
you want but those of us who spank our
children have seen the results we know
that it's effective they're trying to
tell us we're wrong about what we we
ourselves have observed it comes off as
haughty and arrogant I'll still listen
to your show but I'm disappointed in
your position on this PS how do you
reconcile your position with the Bible
which clearly gives parents the
authority to spank okay so let me go
through your points here Joel and then
I'll circle back around and make a few
more general points first of all
importantly I never said that parents
who spank are bad parents never said it
never implied it never said anything
close to that judging by some of my
emails you would think that I said it
but I didn't I simply did not say that
and I don't think it obviously there are
plenty of very good parents who spank
clearly I have always through my whole
career I have urged grace and
understanding for parents I've been very
consistent about this because parenting
is hard I know I have four kids I get it
and and just because a parent makes a
mistake
it doesn't make them bad if it did then
I'd be an awful parent because I make
mistakes all the time am I saying that
spanking is a mistake
yes that's my position that's what I
believe but to say that I think
someone's making a mistake as a parent
it doesn't mean I'm saying that they're
bad it's two different things right or
at least two things that aren't
necessarily don't necessarily go hand in
hand
second do as I say not as I do the point
here is that we don't want to undermine
our authority by exhibiting the very
behavior we're trying to curb in our
children so let's take a less
contentious example of this I always
tell my kids to clean their rooms and to
clean up after themselves and write BNE
respond
a bowl and don't leave stuff laying all
over the place like every other parent
in the world I'm telling my kids that
all the time
well I am NOT the neatest person I'm
pretty disorganized my office right now
you can't see it but there's stuff
strewn all over the place a little
behind the scenes and so my kids they
come into my office and they see what it
looks like
I'm undermining my own authority because
they can see that I'm not following my
own instructions they can see that I
must not take what I'm saying very
seriously because I don't do it so
that's something I need to work on it
doesn't mean that they're excused from
cleaning their room they still have to
do it because that's their
responsibility and just because one
person is not fulfilling their own
responsibilities doesn't mean doesn't
get you off the hook to fulfill yours
but I need to do bet better I know that
and as parents I think we're all guilty
of some do as I say not as I do things
is spanking one of those things I think
it is and I'll explain why first of all
putting a child in timeout is not
doesn't qualify because for one thing
I'm not having to constantly tell my
kids not to put each other in timeout I
don't know about you but that's not the
kind of thing that you're constantly
having to correct in your children is it
hitting is hitting is a big thing that
you have to get your kids not to hit
each other
putting each other and timeout that
doesn't happen very often but for me on
occasion actually it has happened and my
my daughter who's very very maternal
istic and technically the oldest even
though she was a twin but she was the
first to come out and this is a fact
that she's very aware of and and and
makes other people aware of all the time
so she tries the mother of the other
kids and children on occasion she's
actually tried to put them in timeout
and and her brothers have listened to
her and actually gone in timeout
but and I tell her you can't do that my
reason though the reason I give is that
she doesn't have the authority to do it
it's not that putting people in timeout
is bad it's just that it's a matter of
authority and she doesn't have the
authority and actually you could even
argue that
I'm out as a concept i guess i as adults
we do put ourselves in timeout sometimes
just in the in the sense of okay III
need some space I need to step back I
need to calm down
right that's what timeout is sit down
calm down you need to settle down that's
what timeout is all about and as adults
we do kind of do that we don't we don't
call we don't say I'm putting myself in
timeout but it's a similar sort of idea
you could argue taking toys yes I don't
let my kids take other people's toys yet
I do take theirs as punishment sometimes
is that a contradiction no because their
toys aren't really theirs their toys are
mine and I've told them that this is a I
think it's important for them to know
all of their toys are mine and my wife's
those toys belong to mommy and daddy
those are not your toys we graciously
are allowing you to play with them but
we bought them you know we we we are the
ones who if they're we buy them if
they're broken we fix them we pay for
them we pay for everything the house
everything so this is all ours and we
are because we are nice parents we let
you have toys it's your responsibility
to take care of them this is a privilege
you've been given we can retract the
privilege the TV you know all right I we
let you watch TV sometimes but that is
our TV and our couch and so you have to
be grateful and the idea here is not to
have a sense of entitlement so no I
don't take their toys I take my own toys
back from them which yeah they're
allowed to do if somebody has one of
their toys they're allowed to take it
back
they shouldn't be rude about it but yeah
so I don't see that now spanking is
different and here's the issue you
spanked young children right assuming
you're not spanking a 12 year old kid
because that would I hope we all agree
would be really weird and inappropriate
most people spanked kids like 2 to 6 or
there abouts so you have to think about
what they can understand that's what's
important is is there a distinction
between a parent spanking a child and a
child hitting another child yes
obviously there's a distinction but
the child can't see that distinction
than in his mind when you spank him you
you are hitting and you are doing what
you say not to do and this is going to
undermine your authority not to mention
make him feel less safe less secure
because your rules and your words seem
arbitrary to him and that's a problem
so finding some some find sort of
nuanced distinction between spanking and
hitting isn't going to do the job the
child doesn't see fine nuances so here's
the question here's what you have to ask
when you're explaining to your kid why
they shouldn't hit what do you say
assuming you don't just give the because
I said so deal assuming hopefully you've
given them a reason why they shouldn't
do it not because you have to justify
yourself to them but because it they
should understand why your rules are in
place you tell them don't run into the
road if they ask why of course they're
gonna tell them because a car might hit
you so if you tell them don't hit
hopefully you give them a reason so they
can understand the rules and I don't
know what you say here's what I say
here's the reason I give I say that they
should use their words first and express
how they feel with their words if
they're upset or mad or frustrated use
your words
communicate oh but he was mean to me he
did it look I understand he was mean to
you I'm not saying that he was right but
hitting is not the correct way to
communicate your frustration with him
you use your words you communicate we
don't hit we use our words that's that's
the refrain I use with young remember
you're talking about three and four year
old kids you can't get into some
academic dissertation about the
differences of this and that it has to
be very simple they have to be able to
understand it so that's the simple
explanation I also say that hitting is
wrong because it hurts people and we
don't hurt people again simple a
three-year-old can understand it which
is important because I'm saying it two
or three-year-old so they should be able
to know here's the issue that the reason
that I've given use your words don't
hurt people this reason would seem very
much to apply to spanking it would seem
that as the spanking parent I am not
using my words and I am hurting the
child maybe
hurting very much but when a child hits
another child doesn't hurt very much
either would might when my daughter
slaps her brother's I'm thinkin tert
hardly at all but that's not the point
it's not about the degree of injury it's
just it does hurt a little bit and we
don't do that to people so and spanking
does hurt at least a little bit
otherwise why are you doing it and even
if you use your words before and after
spanking it still seems like you are
trying to communicate with violence with
hitting rather than with your words and
and so from the at least it at least
from the child's perspective it is going
to seem very much like a double standard
and so that's something have to take
into account is the spanking so
important to you is it is it is it is it
is the is the plus sides so much of a
plus that it can outweigh the appearance
of a double standard when it comes to
violence
now I argue that it doesn't just appear
to be a double standard I think it
actually is a double standard but my
point is the most you can do is say oh
it only appears to be one well I would
say even that though even if it's only
the appearance of it's still a problem
okay then you say spanking isn't hitting
you provide a definition you say the
definition to strike with the open hand
etc well Joe what's the definition of
strike I'll tell you dictionary to deal
a blow or stroke to a person or thing
semicolon hits so a strike is hit so the
definition of spanking is to hit with
the open hand spanking is hitting
obviously it is impossible to spank a
child without hitting them unless you're
a Jedi using the force here's the
distinction all spanking is hitting not
all hitting a spanking so there's a lot
of very violent and abusive forms of
hitting spanking may not be one of those
forms but it is a form of hitting that's
undeniable just as all bourbon is
whiskey not all whiskey is bourbon
Jupiter is a planet not all planets are
Jupiter right spanking is a subset of a
category
is hitting the categories hitting it is
a subset of that so it is hitting and
this means it is perfectly accurate to
say that when you spank your child you
hit them that is perfectly accurate you
are hitting your child yes there is no
denying that is this you can't deny it
it's in the definition you provided my
point is if it makes you super
uncomfortable to think of spanking as
hitting if it makes you angry when
someone says that you hit your child
then maybe that's a hint that you
shouldn't be doing it if you need the
euphemism then maybe that should tell
you something and it's not like I've
found some absurd roundabout way of
describing spanking to make it sound bad
I had some people say that oh you could
describe any punishment to make it sound
bad by putting someone in timeout is is
uh is is uh is imprisonment right okay
but that's not what I'm doing with
spanking I'm not finding some roundabout
elaborate absurd way of describing it
I'm just defining it there is no way to
define the word spank without the word
hit or a synonym so spank is just a
euphemism it's just it's just a it's a
word that means exactly the same thing
and and so what I'm saying is if if if
the definition of it makes you
uncomfortable maybe that should tell you
something you say what about shouting
yes I think shouting and screaming at a
kid and anger is bad we shouldn't do it
I've done it we shouldn't do it
um I agree we shouldn't do it you know
of course there are extreme cases you
shall pay you don't run in the road kind
of thing but for the most part shouting
and screaming and anger you are venting
your frustrations at your child or about
your child or at least in front of your
child and you should be doing any of
those I do it I have done it I shouldn't
you know I my point here has never been
that I'm the perfect parent that is not
my point and then you bring up the Bible
what does the Bible say well what does
the Bible say about disciplining
children well here's what proverbs says
okay
says withhold not correction from the
child if thou beatest him with the rod
he shall not die thou shalt beat him
with the rod and shalt deliver his soul
from hell
okay Joe let me ask you do you beat your
kid with a rod do you if you don't and I
understand what the Bible says but I
hope you don't beat him with a rod I
mean what if do you be with your kid
with rod and what would you say if you
know one of your kids friends came over
and they had welts on them and you asked
them what are the welts came from and
they've told you that they were being
beaten with a rod by their parents and
don't tell me that beating with a rod
doesn't make welts it does and there's
no way to beat with a rod that doesn't
cause bruises it just doesn't you can't
what would you say would you say oh
that's biblical that's nice or would you
potentially call the police so here's my
point if if you're not beating with a
rod and if you in fact would be
horrified by a parent who beat their
three-year-old with a rod then you are
not taking proverbs as a literal
step-by-step guide for parenting in the
modern age you are not doing that now I
admit that I'm not if your accusation to
me is that I am NOT you know I am not
literally following proverbs the Old
Testament as a guide for discipline my
children you're right I'm not but
neither are you and if you want to say
that I'm you know cherry-picking uh
maybe I am but you're cherry-picking
within the verse itself which seems a
lot more arbitrary now it's one thing to
look at the entire verse and say you
know I think this must be non literal
there must be some metaphor here because
I just you know I can't square the idea
of beating my child with a rod I'm not
gonna do it no way my conscience just
will not allow that
and so it's one thing to say that which
is what I'm saying but what you're doing
is you're looking at this you're picking
apart the sentence itself and
cherry-picking certain words and you
know you like this you don't like that I
don't like rod so I'll make rod
metaphorical beating I don't want to
call it beating I like spanking so what
that to me seems a hell
more arbitrary than what I'm doing and I
admit that even what I'm doing is is
it's it's a little arbitrary I do admit
that because the main reason why I'm
gonna look at that verse as metaphor or
non-literal it's not because of the
context of the verse or because of my
understanding of the original Hebrew or
anything like that it's just because it
strikes me as barbaric to beat a child
with a rod okay that that's my reasoning
but again my point is you have the same
reasoning unless you are actually
beating your child with a rod and I hope
you don't because I I think that's abuse
yes so what do I do with that verse as I
said I take it it I take it as non
literal I think you do I think almost
everybody does okay so those were your
points a few other points in summary as
we wrap up I do think it's relevant that
nearly all the research I've ever read
on this subject has come down against it
research shows that spanking is highly
predictive of violent behavior
antisocial behavior aggression mental
health problems negative relationships
with parents down the line it shows its
predictive even of neurological changes
in the brain when I say predictive I
don't mean causal we cannot prove the
causal relationship that's true but you
can see high degrees of correlation and
you could say all day that correlation
does not equal causation that's true but
it can be indicative of causation and so
there's a lot of very good reason to
think that the correlation here is
indicative of causation that's why the
Academy of Pediatrics for example 67,000
doctors came out against spanking said
it's ineffective and harmful
I'm not saying their word as gospel I'm
not saying that but you talk about your
experience with your child okay but
however you're well behaved your child
is and I'll take you at your word that
he's well behaved but how do you know
he'd be worse if you didn't spank that
unless you've been conducting her
parental experiments on your own child
that's the problem with basing this on
personal anecdotes it's better to look
at the broader picture the large picture
not just personally reported data of
parents who are looking to justify their
own decisions and if you look at the big
picture and the research that's done
almost all of
really almost all of it that I've ever
read and you go looking at yourself has
concluded nearly definitively that
spanking is harmful and the few outlier
studies that I've read for the most part
at best find that maybe it won't heart
be harmful but there has been almost
nothing finding a positive correlation
does that settle it no but it is a
compelling piece of evidence isn't it I
mean if you're told that a certain form
of discipline you're using with your
child that there's been that there's
there's volumes of research done about
it and almost all of that research has
found that it's harmful shouldn't
shouldn't that's cause you at least
pause and think you know maybe there's a
problem here I don't understand how you
could just wave it off I that I don't
understand how anyone could do that I
couldn't that's why I don't spank
because I have read about it and and the
more I've read about it especially
recently I have found it very persuasive
I have no reason to doubt it other than
I would prefer if it weren't true but
that's not good enough
and I think that throws the ball back in
your court considering all the research
on this considering the possibility that
you at least might undermine your
authority by seeming to contradict
yourself considering your own discomfort
with spanking when it is defined in
literal terms considering the risks
involved in using this kind of
disciplinary method considering the
ethical difficulties are always going to
be inherent any time an adult uses
punitive physical force on a small child
considering the possibility that even if
it works it might only work by
instilling fear in your child rather
than respect and love considering that
many established links have been found
between spanking and future aggression
considering all of this why do it what's
the risk of not doing it what's the
positive case for it can you launch a
positive case that outweighs all of the
things I just mentioned I don't think
you can so you know I'm just I'm trying
to justify my position I would say
positively justify yours tell me why you
should do why is it better what reason
do you have to think that it's actually
better than the alternative
aside from your kids are turning out
okay that's not good enough
my kids are turning out okay - and I
don't spank and I've got four of them I
don't know how many you have but you
know we don't wanna get into this
personal back-and-forth that's not what
it's about so there it is that's my hole
that's my whole case but I reiterate for
the tenth time because a lot of people
seem to be confused on this on this
point about what you know what my
personal feelings are I do not believe
or feel that parents who spank are bad
parents or anything close to it I simply
disagree with the method and these are
my reasons all right have a great
weekend everyone
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis clever
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Donovan Fowler audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we will
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there